Постріл!
У роботі мінометника помітний ефект відразу.
Тобто результат твоєї роботи.
Юрію 34 роки, він родом з Харківщини.
До повномасштабного вторгнення хлопець виготовляв і встановлював меблі.
Після 24 лютого хотів приєднатися до ЗСУ, але у військкоматах відмовляли.
Коли займався волонтерством, на блокпості познайомився
з одним військовим. Він через час подзвонив і каже:
ти ж хотів потрапити, створюється бригада "Хартія".
Якщо бажаєш - ось тобі контакти, телефонуй.
Зателефонував, приїхав і лишився з ними.
Віталій - професійний військовий, на службі з 2012 року.
Воював в АТО у складі Нацгвардії. Нині він командир гаубичного дивізіону.
З Юрієм його об'єднує батьківщина - Харківщина, і бригада - "Хартія".
Я знайомий з командиром бригади ще з 2016 року,
коли він був командиром батальйону.
Я навіть не питав, яка посада буде, куди ми йдемо.
Він запропонував, я його знаю, тому я знав що далі ми не будемо
займатися паперовою роботою, а будемо займатися бойовою роботою,
тому я відразу пішов до "Хартії".
"Хартія" - підрозділ, який з'явився в перші місяці повномасштабного
вторгнення на Харківщині. Тоді це було добровольче формування
територіальної громади - близько 200 добровольців,
здебільшого - цивільних. Вони стали одними з перших,
хто вийшов на українсько-російський кордон у Харківській області.
Ось це "кацапія", а це місце перетинання державного кордону.
А он уже український прапор встановила "Хартія".
На цих кадрах - Всеволод Кожемяко - бізнесмен-аграрій,
мільйонер зі списку українського "Форбс",
один зі ста найбагатших людей України у 2020 році.
Навесні 2022-го він створив "Хартію".
Мені один товариш порадив ідею, що можна так зробити.
Я ж в армію… в мене ні освіти немає, нічого, я там не можу бути організатором.
Я можу взяти зброю, піхотинцем можу бути якісним.
Але я ж відчуваю, що я можу більше щось зробити.
І за мною люди, які розглядали мене як якогось лідера.
Це була команда людей, люди, які в мене працювали,
ми в охороні були. І ті, з ким я спілкувався ще з 14-го року,
ці хлопці підтримали. Мої друзі бізнесмени, мої друзі харків'яни активні,
такі як Жадан, наприклад. Один порадив, інший допоміг
оформити документи.
Назву "Хартія" запропонував письменник і музикант Сергій Жадан.
Підрозділ також підтримали тенісисти Еліна Світоліна і Сергій Стаховський.
Та форма, озброєння, пальне, виплати бійцям - спершу все це
фінансувалося за кошти Всеволода Кожемяко і його друзів-бізнесменів.
Проте Кожемяко не вважає "Хартію" своєю приватною армією.
Хоча вона діяла, як фактично, по ефективності, не гірше, а я думаю,
може і краще, ніж приватна військова кампанія.
Але тут же мова йшла не про прибуток, а про те, щоб захищати
рідне місто і рідну землю. Люди були об'єднані певною метою,
вони пасіонарні захисники, вони хотіли цього, і вони мали
певні професії в цивільному житті.
Якщо б війни не було, то вони б не брали в руки зброю, розумієте?
Тому, мабуть, порівняння з приватною військовою кампанією,
воно не стовідсотково працює.
"Хартія" функціонувала як невелике, але самодостатнє формування.
Після звільнення Харківщини воювала на Луганщині,
була єдиним добровольчим підрозділом у Бахмуті.
За словами Кожемяки, його витрати на батальйон сягали мільйонів доларів.
Неможливо це фінансувати без держави, тому що це дуже великі гроші.
Коли це місяць, два, три, пів року, а коли вже рік, а ми провоювали
рік як добровольці, то треба вже в якісь ухвалювати рішення.
Тим більше, що хлопці вже виросли в реальних військових,
реальних фахівців.
Як наслідок, навесні 2023 року "Хартія" стала частиною
"Гвардії наступу" у складі Нацгвардії. Нині це бригада, що формується.
Її бійці проходять навчання і злагодження. До лав підрозділу триває набір.
Обіцяють будь-якого цивільного перетворити на "професійного
винищувача ворога".
Приходять різні люди. Деяких дають військкомати - цивільних.
Деякі переводяться з інших частин. Взагалі дуже різний контингент.
Спостерігаючи за суміжниками, дуже суттєвий результат.
В "Хартії" дуже багато уваги приділяється кожному бійцю і кожній людині.
Людина - це найцінніше, що є. І рівень підготовки в "Хартії" дуже високий.
Ми використовуємо натівські стандарти.
По досвіду з інших частин є дуже великі відмінності.
Перше - це сама робота, планування цієї роботи.
Ми більше приділяємо уваги спланувати це все, перш ніж
виконувати завдання. Для мене це є раціональним і правильним рішенням,
що я вибрав цей підрозділ і цей шлях для себе далі.
Агрохолдинг Всеволода Кожемяко "Агротрейд" нині працює на 80-90 відсотків.
Частина підприємств холдингу пошкоджена, деякі - досі перебувають
в зоні бойових дій. Утім усе, чим він нині займається - це "Хартія".
Формально Кожемяко обіймає посаду радника командувача Нацгвардії.
Бізнесмен каже, що відчуває відповідальність за підрозділ, який створив.
Зараз я намагаюся зберегти те середовище, яке було створено "Хартією".
А це, фактично, середовище патріотів, мотивованих бійців
і патріотів-бізнесменів, які їх підтримують. І спрямовувати ту допомогу,
яку давали "Хартії" як добровольчому підрозділу на бригаду Національної гвардії.
Я ніколи не буваю задоволений, як що функціонує, як що формується.
Бюрократія дуже велика. Можливо, знаєте, я ж теж сприймаю,
як бізнесмен в компанії, навіть великий, як у нас,  рішення приймаються
дуже швидко і втілюються вони дуже швидко. Але ми ж ні від кого не залежимо.
Тут задіяно дуже багато державних установ, це вимагає певної процедури.
І, звісно, що ми десь критикуємо з одного боку, а з іншого розуміємо,
що, можливо, в деяких випадках по-іншому ніяк не вийде.
Бійці "Хартії" певні, що їх досі вирізняє висока мотивація.
Коли бригада сформується й буде наказ командування,
її бійці приєднаються до контрнаступу. Віталій, досвідчений військовий,
який приєднався до бригади нещодавно, готовий ділитися знаннями і досвідом.
Всі втомилися, і я втомився. Але іншого виходу в нас немає.
Кістяк бригади "Хартія" - це добровольці, які звільняли Харківщину.
Серед них і Юрій, який встиг повоювати у Руській Лозовій,
на Луганщині й у Бахмуті.
Ворог зайшов на нашу територію, руйнує наші домівки,
вбиває наших людей. Дуже складно залишатися в стороні й просто дивитися на це.
Вдома на Юрія чекають дружина й син.
Утім хлопець - цивільний в минулому житті -
нині не уявляє себе поза армією.